alright guys we just wrapped on ESL one
cologne the major that isn't a major
arguably the most prestigious tournament
outside of the majors in a csgo calendar
year now ton of great storylines came
out of this one tl winning the intel
grand slam in record time and the big
question mark that surrounds a stralla
s' and the potential of their era ending
we've also got some tantalizing stuff on
the side like coldzera
maybe kind of possibly joining faze clan
and we're gonna break that all down
today with none other than Matt SATA
kissed trivet and also our budget for
the show went up so I have air pods now
[Music]
all right so let's bring them on Matt
what is up hey man how's it going so you
have now got to call to the only two IEM
Grand Slam wins which is yeah kind of
amazing but I actually want to ask you
before we even get into that about a
stralla
because I think the Team Liquid sort of
era dynasty whatever you want to call it
can reasonably said to be said to have
begun but what about the astrologer
is it is it really over or is it just
maybe on pause um first things first
about the two Grand Slams
I didn't expect this to happen again
this quickly so that's incredible for
liquid so I don't even know what I was
gonna say cuz I said like the best of
all time last time and then I was like
[ __ ] now what if I say cuz like
they're gonna do four for four I kind of
like tripped over my words of it but I
was trying to be like like this is
incredible in terms of Australia's look
I think like a lot of the controversy
with with you know I was certainly
involved with calling out blast on
things I think just the community's
perception of them changing
unfortunately because it's nothing
against the team themselves I love those
five players I do things Onix a great
guy I think that that's had some
backlash and I also think that they were
so good for so long you always they're
gonna run into a point whether it's
whether they you know they weren't
attending other events or they lost
motivation to practice or whatever it
was that you're going to have an off
time an off period maybe it's one event
maybe it's a while right now I think
aster always look off genuinely it's not
like this is them not practicing but I
think they can bounce back and I think
sonic said that you know in the
semi-final
against vitality in the pre-interview
and said you know if liquid better win
here or in Chicago because otherwise
we'll be back there's time enough for
them to prepare there's another major
coming I mean if they win another major
and win three in a row and become the
fourth major you know for the first team
to win four major titles then I don't
think we can dispute that they're still
considered to be the number one whether
it's liquid or them we'd have to see
them play off one on one is the era over
maybe if they don't win that major yes
I'm gonna say yes that's kind of my
perspective as well like everyone is
sounding the death knell for Astralis
but I'm thinking if they win the next
major as you say three and a row for
total it would be three in a row in a
system in which we have two majors per
year so just forget about fnatic at that
point it's like doesn't that kind of
make everything that happened between
Katowice and then okay I mean you'd have
to ask them that you'd have to it
depends on your perspective of the
tournament see and certainly they
haven't been putting a lot of priority
into some of the other Maidan main
events so maybe that was their goal
obviously they've missed on a few now in
the end I think cologne was certainly
one that they were hoping to win and get
you know on terms again with with the
Grand Slam because keep in mind for them
to win a second Intel grand slam if that
was their objective or if it was
something that they were hoping to
achieve they were giving away events
they won Katowice which started off
their season that was the start of
season two technically they then missed
three so to win cologne would have put
them as two wins from five events and
they would have only had five more to
close it out so I think I think it
depends on how you look at the team's
objective for me personally I would be
willing to say that it was a part of the
story but it's not like you can just say
all what doesn't matter cuz it still
does it still is why we compete it still
is why there there's teams it still has
to be part of the objective otherwise we
just throw the rest out and only play
majors exactly and then we're just dota
at that point yeah you you brought up a
good point about the length in which tal
got this Grand Slam obviously they did
as best as you can mathematically do
four out of four and that's great is is
it reasonable or unreasonable to say
maybe we should take those four
winds with a grain of salt only because
as you brought up astrologer sort of
deigning not to attend certain events
Dallas was in there and Navi wasn't
there either some of the competition
could be said to not have been as stiff
as say season one I don't know that I
agree with that statement I know what
you're getting at and it's the
astrologer says liquid directly to say
that the competition wasn't as fierce I
don't think that's true
I think the meta has shifted twice
within the time that the season two is
announced we obviously had a heavy
presence that's now been neutered and
nerfed we had the SG come into its own
that's probably I'm gonna say be nerfed
as well soon I can't speak to that like
knowing factually but I would I would
suspect that it will be and we've had
we've had a number of changes including
vertigo come into the map pool so in
some ways you've had ents rise to the
occasion you've had vitality show up in
incredible form lately everyone seems to
be getting more consistent again I might
be are falling off na vi's made changes
I think liquid in terms of the overall
pool have gone through more to achieve
what they did in terms of meta changes
in terms of other teams coming up the
one the one thing they didn't get and
this is where people will talk is well
they didn't have to play a straw list a
lot but keep in mind they did last year
in finals and they gave them good games
they didn't beat them they gave them
good games now I know I buy power at the
start of this year was a shape-up event
and a lot of people didn't take that
seriously but they also did beat them
there and I think at the major they were
so focused on beating a straw list they
took their eyes off the prize and that's
the key ingredient because if we'd had
that kind of it's a liquid a straw was
final we wouldn't even be discussing
this right now because it would have
answered the question it would have
painted the picture if liquid beat them
there no question liquid rises above
them and that's that if they don't beat
them there maybe there's still a debate
and I get it because Astralis aren't
attending so we can't answer the
question one on one which is why I would
love to see that be the next major final
I would love to have that final showdown
even if it's in the playoffs at some
point it still counts but a final would
make it more epic you'd have to really
look at someone like Shawn or chat or
even Yanko obviously not gonna do that
the coaching role but to break down the
demos and and analyze it to tell you who
could be who on any given day right now
on current form liquid bests them but
are we seeing the best of Australis I
don't know so it is kind of unfair
liquid to say well right now I'm gonna
say if they are number one of the world
but to say well we don't know if they're
having an era and I think the next major
if they win that no question and I think
at that point the discussion for best of
all time comes into the quick picture
again because they've just done what
Astralis did and if they finish out the
year in the same way that they're on
right now they actually better they do
better than what a starless achieve last
year I mean this that's pretty
reasonable and you know you can't take
it away from liquid that Australis chose
not to attend events that's certainly
not their fault I wouldn't begrudge them
that I guess like from a storyline
perspective for me just as you know as a
fan as someone really invested as a
content creator as well you know I love
that with season one Australis had a
villain - their superhero right a joker
- their Batman in in liquid and and just
that storyline for liquid didn't really
develop there was no great foil but you
mentioned I want to backtrack a little
bit you mentioned xyu and vitality and
obviously they were super exciting to
watch a cologne and and it's it's
awesome to see that that young man come
into his own and I might be jumping the
gun a little bit here but like are we
worried about getting into a simple
esque situation where yes you know you
could say a generational talent could be
limited by the the pool that that is
that his region represents the
french-speaking CS region yeah yeah
absolutely
yeah simple needs to win a major that
that needs to happen and it let's just
say by the way if we does talking about
eras that could just put that damper on
both of it we'll forget all of it we're
just back to competitive picture overall
I think we do have that fear a little
bit with xyu
the difference I mean look the fact that
they went to the finals and they played
in the finals and he was the only
positive rated player on the team he's
ridiculous that in itself is utterly
insane he single-handedly carried that
team now I say carried it's not like
there wasn't other people stepping up at
times Alex showed good form on CT side
obviously him bringing the end game
leading apex certainly had some solid
multi-kill rounds that had massive
impact for them I think that some of
their mistakes are easy to fix
well easy to identify may be harder to
fix but the anti-eco situations
certainly a large part of the reason
they didn't at least MIT win map one of
the finals why they struggle in the
group stage it's something that they
they hope
fully can address and I think that
they'll come come within their own as a
team I think the ingredients are there
for them I think our PK looked
absolutely sick on dust2
that was the best I've ever seen him
play in csgo that was old school source
material from him and if they can get
that out of everyone then then they're
there and I don't know who you would
even change to make that team better
right now that's the difference where's
in Navi we looked at constant players
that were underperforming and we had a
larger time frame to say okay that's
another performance that's not them
developing or still needing to develop
that's them just missing off or falling
off completely yeah God like I'm
starting to get desperate for simples
sake you know the boom each move is like
a good one just flat-out you know I
think even casual viewers can can tell
that but with how you know incredible
liquid is looking and our possible
straws
return to strength looming and with you
know guys like zaboo coming up I kind of
look at that team and I just I just
wonder if simple is ever gonna get there
boo Mitch is great that's fine
but it still feels like it felt last
year and the year before that and I fall
into this trap and I know actually the
guys on the desk at Cologne discussed
this a little bit about mixed language
rosters or rosters that communicate in
languages that are not their first
language but I fall into this this maybe
fan trap of saying like my god I would
love to see simple put with X Y and Zed
or fate of this team or go to that team
that is outside the CIS region yeah
let's not forget he was on liquid at one
point the last Cologne of course what
was in he was there I mean he's played
outside of the region before and and had
mixed results I think decent success you
know lost in a semi-final in Columbus to
LG in very dramatic fashion then went on
to Cologne at the next major to play in
the finals and still fall shy so yeah I
mean he's tried it before it is true I
think that the problem is that the CIS
region is the same place that every
region was in and now Brazil's finding
themselves in younger talent is coming
through and the meta is shifting and
some of the older guard aren't either
adapting or maybe are just simply not as
talented as some of these young guys so
there's
we make the changes they brought an
electronic is really good boom which
coming in it's it's you know you've got
to mix youth with experience right now I
think to be a top team and and I think
simple house to stay there but yeah III
if he doesn't win this I think for me if
you know four storylines whether liquid
astrology or Navi win would be perfect
for all three of the reasons we've
talked about for each respective team
and and I think that they have to win
one of the next year it's simple I think
you're right um I got I gotta say I this
is a tangent I love electronic to death
I think he's incredible I've been
singing his praises since flipside
tactics I think he was awesome in
Cologne so if it's just it's it's those
two I when I look at Navi like I just
have this imaginary line that's divided
it's those two and then everybody else
you brought you brought up Brazil and
and that's a really interesting regional
test case to see what's happening there
with furia and the former SK gaming now
MIB are obviously right now the hot
topic in that region is called Zara
looking to step back from the team the
big rumors obviously maybe faze clan
Keough tweeted a picture of him and Nico
phasing up in some kind of casino yeah I
you know I have a soft spot for faze
clan I don't think that's really much of
a secret at this point and I kind of
love the storyline slash mean that it
does become a retirement home for once
great csgo players so I kind of want
cold to be there but yeah I also it I
also at the same time don't know if
that's the solution for a super team on
paper that has been anything but for the
last two years yeah really since the
cloud9 lost in the finals at the major
and then cadidates too followed that up
same thing I don't know I don't know
it's a weird one for me I I don't want
to get too vocal in some of the opinions
I have about that team because I don't
think that they're based on skill I
think they're based on attitude and I
don't know if it's true but just
speculation I think that there might be
some they get along really well outside
the game but I think there might be some
issues in game that might be holding
them back I know ingame leadership
certainly been an obvious one and
they've made changes to bring in Neill
but getting rid of neo again already and
bringing in cold or going back to Nico
and game leaving I personally don't
think
Nicko ingham leading was the answer and
I don't think it was a good thing for
them in the long run so yeah it's a
tough one for me and interestingly to go
on the other side of it what does it
mean for em IVR coulded hinted in the
past that he actually was potentially
wanting to go to liquid and join taco
which actually would have meant that
Twist was gonna be the one that they
were wanted to poach to go to MIB R and
it never really materialized it never
really got anywhere it was them talking
more than the orgs and it's it's
interesting to think that they they
would lose what is the centerpiece of
that team in a lot of ways I know fall
and as the spiritual leader but cold has
been the skill pushing that force and I
don't know what happens to either party
if it works because like you say phase
has so much skill but still aren't
making it work so does he suddenly fix
them does he motivate them i I don't
know and I also don't know if he's even
going to phase certainly that seems to
be the rumor that has the most weight
behind it but we'll see I mean I I hope
those teams need help I don't know what
fixes it that's not that's not my job I
guess I just sit back and see what
happens
Matt thank you so much for making time
I'm gonna let you go now and maybe you
can get a few hours of relaxation in
after your busy schedule but yeah thank
you so much for making time it's been an
awesome chat thank you so much looking
forward to talking as again soon all
right Matt so I'm just going to pretend
that we just got you on the line I just
called you on the phone do that [ __ ]
ain't man yeah yeah yeah do it in that
voice - I will Matt what is up hey man
how's it going you did do the voice I
day I did